what is the state of the brothers today
is the rift as broken as we from the
outside looking in think it is
are we making more of it or are they
really
kind of done with each other
right now it looks like they're done
with each other but you know they've
both said especially harry has often
said i owe my brother so much we've been
through hell together i love him to bits
but
you know that was just before all of
this happened i think there's no no
other two people who've been through
what they've been through on the planet
so we'll have to wait and see i mean
it's a toss-up look there are two guys
now who aren't talking to each other
william is not returning harry's calls
charles hasn't spoken to harry in a very
very long time he's cut him off
financially and in the future by the way
i think charles is going to really could
conceivably
permanently exclude them uh from the
royal family i hate to to be the person
who says the women could fix it
but don't you think megan and kate could
go a long way to bridging
a gap if they showed a little bit of a
unified front or made good with each
other it could be up to them and i think
the key element here is the fact that
uh harry and kate are so close
i think she has more leverage than your
average sister-in-law and uh yeah i
think that and if they saw it was in
their self-interest to do it i don't
think obviously harry doesn't want to
you know be
left out completely he tried to come
up with a part-time solution the queen
said no you know this is not what we do
in the firm you're either in a year out
but maybe charles could be convinced
otherwise it'll be a lot better frankly
for charles to have both of his sons up
there on the balcony what's interesting
about the whole relationship between uh
william and harry is that that
incredible brotherly bond that i wrote
about 20 years ago in diana's boys
it seems stronger than any normal bond
could ever possibly be and looking back
uh now i see that the seeds were already
sort of planted
uh for for the rift that exists today i
mean even when he was four years old
right
harry would say you know uh you william
you have to behave because you're going
to be king i'm not going to be king so i
can do anything i want right but you
also laid out in the book it it seemed
like actually
it was william acting out a lot of the
time but getting away from it but
harry's still getting the brunt of
everything well this really came in into
focus uh and by the way even when
there's small children i mean i have a
really poignant photograph in the book
which is harry's first day of school and
he's excited that he goes up to the
teacher and he sticks his hand out to
shake her hand and she reaches right
over his head
to shake william's hand and charles has
every important one when when harry and
william went to see the queen mother uh
the queen mother would would sit with
william but harry had to sit in a corner
apart from them i mean william was
always going to be king he was always
treated differently but this really came
into focus in a big way
when harry was 16 and he was caught you
know smoking pot and drinking at the
rattle bone inn well william is the
person who introduced him to the rattle
bonus williams william is the guy he had
a lot of those stumbled out oh man a lot
of bad scenes with william there and yet
william never got in trouble harry got
in huge trouble uh in 20 and 2005 the
famous incident where
harry uh you know dresses up in a nazi
uniform to go to a costume party william
helped him pick out that costume but
william never took any heat for it harry
was crucified around the world in the
press rightly so right right right but
you know it was a stupid stupid thing to
do but again william
seemed to be made of teflon uh later on
when
harry was uh photographed uh you know
naked with a girl in a hotel room in las
vegas right we all remember those yeah
that one yeah but you know uh william
didn't come to his defense didn't come
to defense at any of the during any of
those incidents uh harry was on the
verge of a nervous breakdown at that
point and the one thing i have to give
william credit for is that he did step
in and say look
the way you're acting this is not right
you've got to get a therapy and so he
really you know harry credits william
with saving his life for for 20 years
they've both been burying
uh the grief and pain they felt
surrounding their mother's death i think
the defining moment for the two
uh brothers was walking behind their
mother's
coffin you know in silence through the
streets of london with a million people
weeping they could hear a little girl uh
who's one of the ones like people lining
the road saying uh mummy mummy look
there's the box with the princess you
know that kind of thing stays with you
and even to this day harry says when he
gets on a plane and flies to london it
triggers all sorts of terrible emotions
they both really suffer from undiagnosed
symptoms of ptsd
[Music]